il est traduit bien venu sur le plateau
de c signé en direct et en public à la
poudrière besançon bonsoir ils sont
rares ceux qui ont toujours su rester
fidèles à ce qu'ils sont tu connais
m'biwi michel pee wee un drôle d'oiseau
ce michel puisons carrure de moineaux
lunettes rondes poètes libertaires
chanteur père de famille journaliste
collègues et amis bonsoir quatre morts
dans le jura suite à un carambolage
c'est le lourd bilan d'un accident
survenu cet ami a tout connu le noir et
blanc la couleur car est la parole sans
retenue ce même en direct alors j'ai une
petite anecdote là quand même je
voudrais signaler quand même au vieil
ivrogne acariâtre qui gardent les
grilles il ya deux jours qu'il gardait
les grilles que la foire comtoise en
fait mort a coûté à peu près 150 prend
pour aller remercier tout coeur merci
ce soit au sommaire de notre magazine
michel bise on sait la culture avant
tout 42 ans de carrière et des émissions
qui ont bousculé france 3 franche comté
et fertois comme on disait on y croise à
ses potes
christian décamps chanteur du groupe
planche même claude nougaro a fait
l'éloge de michel buzon l'horizon
artistes le pierrot lunaire au cet album
depuis son premier séduction poussière
en 85
[Musique]
tapas et de l'envié d'écrire à l'envi de
faire des spectacles de composer des
musiques et de mettre tout ça en mesure
de faire des chansons
il est plusieurs choses il ya monsieur
qui est dans le coup c'est léo ferré je
trouve qu'il portait très loin la poésie
et la chanson
la musique et puis j'avais ce besoin
physique de contact direct et important
le chant déjà une chance et physique que
c'est un facteur qui manquait et je suis
trouvée je coachais de trouver un
aboutissement
parce que cherchait depuis longtemps à
travers l'écriture
[Musique]
léo lui n'aura embêter personne hormis
disons le quelques directeur michel
pilon et poil à gratter mais jamais
méchant ce soir c'est nos dernières
petites conneries nos dernières images
nos derniers crachats et puis bon
j'espère que notre nouveau directeur and
love rock'n'roll bonjour monsieur le
directeur y aime le rock c'est que je
suis sûr que plus rockeur des
journalistes a aujourd'hui trois fois 20
ans il même un peu plus tout le monde
tout le rock n roll on dit en espérant
qu'il sera en forme on va renaître de
nos 100 200 il nous parlera il écrira
encore demain tout à l'heure alors salut
l'artiste et merci michel bon dimanche à
tous au revoir